oh boy it's that time again talking
about some horrible films people some
really terrible things that I sat
through this year the worst films of
2016 and to continue last year's
tradition since we're talking about some
ugly movies I wore an ugly sweater look
let's just get into this okay cuz these
movies are the worst they are so bad
these are the films that I sat through
this year and just I questioned why I
was doing it and I wondered what I was
doing with my life that happens a lot
let's start out with some dishonorable
mentions congradulations inferno you
sucked way to go
collateral beauty you were ass great job
Assassin's Creed you proved that even
with an actor like Michael Fassbender
acting in and producing your film that
video game movies are just always gonna
be bad forever alright it's come down to
this my 10 least favorite movies of 2016
starting with oh the darkness why was
this movie made why was Kevin Bacon in
this movie what happened here this was
one of the worst horror films of the
year in a year filled with some pretty
terrible horror films and some
surprisingly good ones the darkness
really stood out as a piece of poop it
was really bad I hated it
[Music]
gods of Egypt
okay this movie was hilarious I've sat
in this theater and I just didn't care I
laughed out loud I didn't care I was
just laughing this movie was hilarious
this was the closest out of the ten
worst of the Year films that I have this
year that I thought was maybe like a
hilarious 'ti we could actually possibly
watch it and enjoy it and laugh there's
a few others like that we'll get to in a
minute but this film was so self serious
and it was so awful and just about
everything it tried to do that it just
collapsed within itself and I almost
kind of appreciated it shut in what I
mean what was this movie this was one of
the most boring films I saw all year
this film had no reason to exist Naomi
Watts wandered around a house for 90
minutes and there's a horribly contrived
twist that ruins any enjoyment you may
have had previously it's it every single
horror movie cliche you could possibly
imagine there's an animal that pops out
there's horrible jump scares dream
sequences that leads to nothing shuttin
is one of the worst horror films I've
ever seen oh shit max steel I think I'm
the only person on the planet that
actually saw this movie I saw this alone
in a theater and it was so bad about 20
minutes in and I just popped out my
iPhone and started taking notes for
every terrible thing that happened so I
can make a really in-depth review of it
and man I mean I had a lot to talk about
this is easily the worst superhero film
of the year if you can call it a
superhero film a lot of people did not
see this movie and for good reason I
struggled to comprehend why this movie
was made it feels like one of those
rights retaining movies like oh shit we
want to keep our rights to max steel in
case ever one day we want to make an
oscar-worthy max steel film because
that's going to happen so we should make
max steel and just get it out and people
will see it or not not
[Music]
the other side of the door got bad
reviews but way better reviews than it
should have I hated this movie I again
laughed a lot during this film another
really bad horror film awful plot
contrivance is that made the movie
collapse within itself the ending was
also a horrific letdown
another really self-serious movie that
thinks it's amazing and it's not it was
really bad I can't believe I went to a
theater and sat through this film what
why do I do that to myself and am I just
like masochist look I said this in my
review but when the bough breaks is
Screen Gems September movie with the
same actors shuffled over and over again
they've been doing it for the past like
four years and they all make a lot of
money compared to their budget that's
all they do they're like hey what's the
Lifetime channel movie we can make this
year well will switch out Morris
Chestnut or maybe this time we'll do
Michael Ealy I will trade them off over
and over again and we'll just make the
same movie and just reshuffle the plots
it's all fatal attraction there's just a
bunch of fatal attraction ripoffs Sarli
do movies horrible hated it it was
fucking terrible this piece of shit I
had to sit there and there were like two
other people in front of me and they
looked bored as shit and they actually
seemed like they wanted to see the movie
they were excited for a minute and then
they were just like my god this sucks
and they were like falling asleep on
each other's shoulders I wanted to fall
asleep but I had to pay attention to win
the bow breaks because I have to do
reviews of these movies why did I
fucking see this movie why didn't I go I
think I just got on camera
my official nervous breakdown about why
I see terrible films I should leave it
all in
[Music]
you know I was actually kind of excited
for sale because I'm a fan of the movie
1408 a Stephen King adaptation starring
John Cusack and samuel l.jackson this is
also a Stephen King adaptation starring
those actors but Wow
this one was laughably bad if you're not
laughing your ass off by the opening
Airport scene well then I guess you just
don't watch a lot of movies because that
was some horribly directed shit and the
entire film is like that and it leads to
an ending that is so horrible and it
makes no sense and it looks I mean it
looks like Adobe After Effects it's so
bad CEL is awful it's one of the worst
Stephen King adaptations of all time and
there are a lot of bad ones you know I
thought about putting over the North a
lot higher on this list because of how
truly awful it was there were children
behind me in this theater who were
Restless they were like mommy I want to
go home I want to do something else I'd
rather play et the Atari game mommy I
don't know what that is but I'd rather
do that than watch norm of the north and
I was like yeah me too give me Superman
64 right now I'll do it fuck but I
didn't put this piece of shit
higher on my list because it's an
animated film with a polar bear voiced
by Rob Schneider and it was originally
meant to go straight to DVD and blu-ray
and they just kind of shoved it in
theaters so when he looked at it like
that like okay I can kind of understand
why this is so bad it was their mistake
to put this in theaters because now I'm
talking about this shitty movie but at
the same time I can't quite say it's the
worst film of the year because the other
two films I still have to talk about had
a lot more potential
[Music]
yeah this sucks
ah yeah this movie sucks hey baby
look at that chick Kate Beckinsale she's
pretty hot
if you guys saw my review of the
disappointments room I had a lot of
people tell me that they enjoyed my
boobs and butt and impression so I
thought I'd do it again for the worst
horror film 2016 this movie had some
potential it was directed by DJ Caruso I
enjoyed the movie disturbia it was an OK
disposable horror film Kate Beckinsale
was in this film she has shown herself
to be a good actress and some things
like love and friendship and I enjoy her
in the underworld movies even though
they got consistently worse this movie
had potential it could have actually
been a good movie but it's so chopped up
and horrific aliy edited that the actual
film doesn't make sense anymore I've
looked into the production of this movie
and they just basically gave up
relativity Studios went bankrupt and
they were like just fuck it just release
it sometime just put it out there who
cares if it's finished there's so much
shit removed from this movie that the
actual film as a whole just doesn't hold
up as a movie it was so painful to watch
okay guys my number one most hated film
of 2016 is Nine Lives has actually
developed a bit of a cult following in
lieu of movies like the room that type
of cult following a movie that's so bad
you can watch it and just be amazed at
the fact that this exists but I'm
looking at a movie directed by Barry
Sonnenfeld the guy who made men in black
and starring Kevin Spacey and
Christopher Walken and I'm wondering why
this film about a guy who gets turned
into a cat exists how did this happen
the reason this is my number one beyond
the fact that I hated everything about
this movie is because all of these
people coming together to make this is
baffling to me the potential there for
people who are funny and who have proven
themselves to be funny in the past and
who have proven themselves to be good
directors in the past is mind-boggling
that this is the result that we got when
I first saw the trailer for this movie I
thought it was a Funny or Die sketch but
no it's actually the movie it's real
it's kind of incredible actually how did
this movie get made it's
insane somebody had to have some crazy
blackmail on these people my god this
movie got made people oh well guys those
are my least favorite films of 2016 I do
have one more thing I want to say I want
to give a big thank you to a very cold
viewer out there
his name is Matthew Matthew sent me a
poster for nine lives aren't you a peach
Matthew why would you do that to me I
know you are getting at there buddy that
is a hilarious gift Matthew is actually
the son of one of the receptionist who
works at my orthodontist and I really
appreciated getting that gift from you
it made me laugh quite a bit thank you
very much for that gift guys thank you
for watching my videos in 2016 it's been
a blast it's been a lot of fun even
watching these movies and reviewing them
I get some horrible weird enjoyment out
of it I don't know it's like therapeutic
guys you are the best I look forward to
talking to you very soon in the year
2017 have a great rest of the year and
as always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you